The earliest event in the Saw timeline is the birth of John Kramer, aka
Jigsaw in 1953 or 1954.
We know this because at the time of his death in 2006, they mention his age.
-[Doctor] Subject's name is John Kramer, a 52 year old male Caucasian.
Over the next 30 years, the Saw timeline is pretty uneventful.
Other than the birth of some major characters.
We don't have exact dates for
most of them, but based on their ages in the movies, I'd estimate that
Lawrence Gordon was born in the 1950s and Mark Hoffman, Eric Matthews and Amanda Young
were born in the 1960s.
We do know that Hoffman's sister Angelina was born in 1971 or 1972, which we
can deduce from a newspaper article showing that she was 25 at the time of
her death in 1997.
Then there's Logan Nelson, born August 18, 1973, and
Steven Singh, born in 1975 or 1976, which we can do the math on based on his age at the time of
his death in 2004.
-[Rich] A raid that also resulted in the death of Tapp's partner, 28 year old Stephen Singh.
While the birth dates of these characters aren't super important to the
story, I found that I can use similar logic to determine the dates of almost
everything that happens in the series and create the ultimate timeline that
can help us better understand everything about the Saw lore and answer
questions that have always confunded fans.
So if you want to know the date and order of events of everything in the
franchise, stick around to the end of this video.
Thank you to BetterHelp for sponsoring this video.
♪ Metal Music ♪
Jigsaw, the titular villain of the Saw saga, is most known for his puzzles.
In order to solve many of his games and traps, you have to put together the
puzzle pieces.
I even did a character analysis episode where I put together the pieces of
Jigsaw's life.
Fittingly the Saw timeline is also a puzzle.
There are no title cards or graphics.
To display the dates and the movies are known for their flashbacks within
flashbacks and non linear storytelling but there are clues hidden
throughout about when certain things take place.
If you want to know when
Dr. Lawrence Gordon graduated from college, for example, you'll have to zoom
into his diploma behind the desk June 4, 1979.
This has led many Saw fans to wonder, what if you put everything in
chronological order? Does the story still work? Or will this create
paradoxes and contradictions? After all, if Dr. Gordon graduated
when his diploma says he did, that makes him probably as old as John Kramer.
What I found is that for the most part, the Saw timeline
is one of the most well thought out and accurate horror movie timelines out there.
There are a few things that don't make sense, but most of them can be explained.
Overall, the puzzle pieces actually fit together really nicely,
and this was a really fun puzzle to solve.
I know the Saw fans have been asking for this ever since
I put together a timeline for my horror history episodes a few years ago.
Since then, I've noticed some things and made this timeline even more accurate.
So let's take it back to the next point of importance in the Saw
story the 1980s.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
It would have likely been somewhere around 1983, when Adam Stanheit, who
would go on to be a photographer and one of John Kramer's many victims, got
a preview of that pain on his 6th birthday.
-[Adam] On my 6th birthday, my best friend at the time, Scott Tibbs,
-[Adam] a rusty nail.
-[Adam] I didn't tell you about that.
Then there's the early career of Detective Mark Hoffman before eventually
going on to be Jigsaw's first successor.
He became a cop sometime in the early 1980s.
-[Mark] I've been a cop for 20 years.
John Kramer himself went on to be a civil engineer, creating his first
building, the Gideon Meatpacking Plant, sometime in the mid to late 80s.
Shortly after this, he teamed up with lawyer Art Blank to start the
Urban Renewal Group to create low income housing.
One of these homes is the location later known as the nerve Gas house.
Meanwhile, one of Hoffman's earliest cases involved the investigation of an
abusive teacher with his partner, Daniel Rigg.
Things escalate, and Rigg punches the teacher but avoids charges because
Hoffman lies on his behalf.
Don't get any ideas.
No punching the Horror History professor.
That is, if you want to live.
Sometime around 1990, Metropolitan Police Detective Eric Matthews and his
wife have a son named Daniel.
We don't have any clues to his date of birth other than the fact that he
seems to be around 15 years old during the Nerve Gas House Game in 2005.
Around the time of Daniel's birth, the marital troubles start for
Eric and his wife, likely due to Eric's infidelity.
Sometime in the early 90s, Hohn meets his future wife, Jill Tuck.
Jill is a doctor who works with recovering drug addicts.
She starts her own practice called Homeward Bound Clinic.
The movie Homeward Bound was released in 1993, so one might assume that
Jill was trying to capitalize off that popularity.
It makes sense that this would also be around the time that she founded the
clinic, which was opened before she got pregnant in 1994.
The clinic's motto is cherish your life, a phrase that John would later
repeat to some of his victims.
No wonder they were soulmates.
Jill holds a party at her clinic, where John meets insurance company mogul
William Easton.
John doesn't like how William uses a formula to determine who gets health
coverage and essentially who lives and dies.
John isn't a psychopath yet, so William avoids going on his list.
For now, we'll revisit this.
The reason that we know all of this takes place in the early 90s is because
John and Jill plan to have a baby in the Chinese year of the pig.
John plots it this way because the pig is a symbol of rebirth, which is
central to both John and Jill's work.
The Year of the Pig occurs every twelve years, meaning that these events
occur in either 1995 or 2007.
John does not survive to 2007, so it has to be 1995, meaning their son
Gideon was likely conceived in April 1994, nine months before
the Chinese New Year.
While Jill is pregnant, John becomes increasingly concerned about her safety
on the job, noticing some suspicious patients at her clinic, specifically a
man named Cecil Adams, who John one day had to convince to put away his
knife during an altercation.
The incident foreshadows the tragic night where everything changes in
November of 1994.
We know this because John states that Jill was seven months pregnant at the time.
-[John] This is my wife.
-[John] She's pregnant.
-[Doctor]How far along?
-[John] Seven months.
While Jill is locking up for the night, Cecil threatens her at knifepoint so
that he can steal some meds.
He storms out and slams the door into Jill's stomach, causing her to miscarry.
The loss of his son devastates John, sending him into a dark
depression where he distances himself from his wife and his work, causing
his marriage to slowly fall apart.
On January 31, 1995, during the previously mentioned Year of the Pig celebration
John donning a pig mask kidnaps Cecil, making him his first victim.
Just be glad he didn't choose Year of the Rooster, I guess.
Those masks are strangely terrifying.
Cecil awakens in John's workshop, where he takes part in John's first trap,
the Knife Chair.
He manages to escape that one, but he tries to retaliate landing him in the
razor wire cage where he ultimately met his fate.
This is where we first see John cut a jigsaw piece out of Cecil's body,
which would eventually earn him the nickname Jigsaw and inspire the 1997
Will Smith song Getting Jiggy With It.
All I can say is it better be in Saw X.
Jill attempts to give John another chance.
After months of him distancing himself and joined by Art Blank, she visits
him at his workshop at Gideon Meatpacking Plant.
John seemingly hasn't recovered at all and kicks them out.
Jill tried to go back one more time alone but didn't make any progress, and
this was effectively the end of their relationship.
I'm guessing these were still both in early 1995, because when Jill goes the
second time, there are still reconnaissance photos of Cecil lying around.
We can also see at this point he's already started working on designing some
of the famous traps which he would use later on, such as the rack and the
glass coffin.
These traps almost most never come to fruition though.
Shortly after Jill leaves him, John is diagnosed with cancer.
The combination of a miscarriage, divorce, and cancer diagnosis is too much
for him to handle, and he decides to drive off a cliff and end his life.
But against all odds, he survives.
And this near death experience makes him appreciate life in a way that he
never had before.
His faith in the rehabilitation method he had tried and failed on Cecil was restored.
This was still nearly a decade before the events of Saw, but
despite that, there are still a lot of events to unpack before that fateful
day when he put himself face down on the bathroom floor.
(IMPACT)
All of this talk of horror movie timelines reminds me some of you who are
struggling may want to get the timeline of your life back on track.
That's why today's video is sponsored by BetterHelp, the online platform for
professional therapy.
It's secure professional therapy online, available worldwide.
You can log into your account anytime and send a message to your therapist.
You'll get timely and thoughtful responses.
Plus, you can schedule weekly video or phone sessions, so you won't ever
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting room again.
Unless you want to.
BetterHelp is all about facilitating therapeutic matches based on your
needs, so they make it super easy to change therapists if needed.
It's more affordable because you're not paying for therapist office space,
and they even offer financial aid.
BetterHelp wants you to start living a happier life today.
Just visit BetterHelp.com/CZsWorld
That's BetterHelp for 10% off your first month.
That's BetterHelp.com/CZsWorld
for 10% off.
Take charge of your mental health now.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Over the course of the next five to seven years so basically 1995 through 2002,
John began to pay more attention to the world around him as he
continued to receive chemotherapy for his colon cancer.
He came to meet some of the other people who he deemed as unappreciative of
their lives and planned to include them in his upcoming test game.
He also meets with his insurance provider, William Easton, to request
coverage for an experimental cancer therapy in Norway.
But his request is denied, and this time, William is added to his list.
Told you it was coming back.
While Jigsaw might mostly be laying low for a while, some other notable
events happen during this time.
In 1995 or 1996,
Dr. Lawrence Gordon and his wife give birth to a daughter, Diana Gordon, which
we know because she was eight years old at the time of the bathroom game.
-[Rich] During the home invasion involving his wife and eight year old daughter.
As previously stated, in 1997, Detective Hoffman'sister was murdered by her
boyfriend, Seth Baxter, during a domestic dispute.
We can see this date on a computer screen in Saw V.
Hoffman does not take this well and becomes an alcoholic, which in turn
causes John Kramer to take notice of him as someone who is not cherishing life.
As you may know, court cases can take as long as a year to resolve
sometimes, and that's exactly what happens here.
In 1998, Baxter was sentenced to 25 years in prison.
However, he would be released early after serving only five years in 2003.
And 2003 minus five years is 1998.
That's how I know when he was sentenced.
Rounding out the millennium with 1999, this was most likely the year that
Logan Nelson graduated from medical school and began his residency at the
Angel of Mercy Hospital, where he would work under
Dr. Gordon and cross paths with John Kramer.
This is just me assuming that he went straight through school and did not
take any breaks, which I believe is typical.
Also in 1999, Hoffman saves the life of fellow Metropolitan Police officer
Matt Gibson from a junkie during a distress call at the old Crossroad Factory.
Hoffman orders the perp to drop his gun, and he complies, but
Hoffman shoots him anyway.
Hoffman thinks he's doing a favor to Gibson, but Gibson reports Hoffman for
Brutality!
Feels good to bring that one out again.
About a year later, in 2000, Hoffman gets promoted for saving Gibson's life,
while Gibson gets transferred to Internal Affairs, where he busted three of
Hoffman's men.
-[Gibson] Year later, I transferred to IA,
-[Gibson] busted three of his guys.
-[Gibson] He swore he'd get me back.
This is probably also around the time of various police brutality incidents
on behalf of Detective Eric Matthews.
What brutality?
By 2003, John was deep into planning his first game, which
would be a test game held in private.
And just to clarify, a game is a test involving multiple people and multiple traps,
while a trap is a single test involving one or more people.
He had found four contestants for his game, and he would find his fifth
before long when Logan Nelson accidentally switched up his x-rays with that
of another patient, causing a delay in his treatment.
This sealed Logan's fate as the fifth contestant.
So in early 2003, John Kramer held his Barn Game.
However, Logan didn't wake up in time for the beginning of the game, causing
John to bail him out, not wanting Logan to die over an honest mistake.
Technically, John Kramer's Barn Game could have taken place anywhere between
John's cancer diagnosis and Logan's time in the military.
So I'm putting it as late as possible on the timeline due to the presence of
advanced technology.
After saving his life, Jigsaw helped Logan rebound and Logan became his
first apprentice.
Together, they created the Reverse Bear Trap.
After getting back on his feet, Logan served in the military as a medic and lieutenant.
According to his file, he shipped out in May of 2003.
There he served alongside Keith Hunt.
-[Brad] You two know each other?
-[Keith] Logan was a medic in Fallujah.
It was also around this time in three that Jigsaw must have conducted his
earliest set of individual traps.
But these, as far as we know, are never seen in any Saw movie.
So how do I know that they happen? Well, this is right before Mark Hoffman
attempted to create his own copycat jigsaw trap, the Pendulum.
The Barn Game was never discovered by police.
So in order for this copycat crime to make sense, there had to have been
other Jigsaw traps that were discovered by police in the first place.
Even though we don't see them on this list of Jigsaw victims in Saw V.
Maybe there's another page to this list that we don't see.
Or maybe they were all so badly mutilated that they could not be identified.
There is actually further proof of their existence, though.
In 2016, Logan Nelson created some new Jigsaw audio by splicing together
audio from old tapes.
This was before Voice.ai
He splices in words that aren't from any of the Jigsaw tapes that we've seen
in saw one through seven.
-[Jigsaw] The games have begun again.
-[Jigsaw] And they will not stop until the sins against the innocent are atoned for.
-[Jigsaw] I will take care of the next four.
-[Jigsaw] You take care of the rest.
So this audio could have come from the extra victims in 2003, which had to
happen before May 2003, the month that Seth Baxter was released from prison
on a technicality.
I know he was released in May because at the scene of his death in June,
a detective states that he got out one month ago.
-[Detective] Typical bio murder convict.
-[Detective] Served five years.
-[Detective] Just released last month.
But CZ, how do you know his death took place in june? Well, it's right here
in the next day's newspaper dated June 11, which would probably come out the
day after.
Meaning Hoffman plays seth Baxter in the Pendulum Trap on June 10, 2003.
But CZ, how do you know it's 2003 and not 2004? Because by 2004, Hoffman was
already helping Jigsaw set up traps.
The Pendulum happened before hoffman met Jigsaw, so it has to be 2003.
I really did my homework this time.
Obviously it's shortly after the Pendulum when John finds out about the
copycat crime and punishes Hoffman for it.
with a trap called the Shotgun Chair.
Hoffman is converted into a Jigsaw follower and would help out with future
traps as John's physical condition continues to weaken.
Next up, June 2003.
John Kramer was diagnosed with an inoperable frontal lobe tumor.
We know this because John's medical report dated March 24, 2004 is shown and
the initial diagnosis is said to be nine months earlier.
So it's time for him to really get to work.
He probably doesn't have long to live and he's still got a lot of people to rehabilitate.
In late February 2004, John, with Hoffman's help kidnaps
Paul Leahy and places him in the Razor Wire Maze.
-[Jigsaw] You are a perfectly healthy, sane, middle class male.
-[Jigsaw] Yet last month you ran a straight razor across your wrist.
I'm no doctor, but doesn't seem to me like Paul was a perfectly healthy and
sane individual.
As Paul bleeds to death in the trap, John and Hoffman observe through a peephole.
This is also when John tasks Hoffman with placing
Dr. Gordon's pen light at the scene of the next trap
in order to throw off the police.
I'm placing this in February 2004 because it's three weeks before police
found Paul's body on March 19, 2004.
-[Kerry] This one's not fresh anymore, at least three weeks out.
The next subject would be Mark Wilson, who had to contend with the
Flammable Jelly Trap.
They chose Wilson because he was faking an illness, and this would be the
one where Hoffman left behind
Dr. Gordon's pen light.
I'm just kind of assuming that both of these traps occurred before police
start finding stuff.
They first find Paul on March 19, then Mark shortly after that, finding
Dr. Gordon's pen.
John's medical situation continues to get worse.
On March 24, 2004, he gets more cancerous growth that affect his ability to
speak and move the right side of his body.
But these ailments would not stop him from overseeing his most iconic trap
yet.
(IMPACT)
♪ Static Music ♪
In May 2004, John would bring in two more homeward bound patients,
Amanda Young and Donnie Greco, for his Reverse Bear Trap.
We know this date because
Dr. Gordon cites that it was five months ago while he's chained up in the
bathroom in October, which I'll get to.
Amanda kills Donnie and takes the
key from his stomach to unlock the trap.
When Amanda gets out, she doesn't immediately go to police because we can
see her wounds appealed a bit before then.
The detectives soon bring in
Dr. Gordon for questioning regarding his penlight at the crime scene,
and Dr. Gordon confesses his whereabouts.
He was having an affair.
Immediately after, they interrogate Amanda, who praises Jigsaw for his
rehabilitation method.
When she gets home after everything, John is there waiting for her.
He takes her under his wing and brings her into Jill's clinic as evidence
that his methods can turn a person's life around in ways that Jill's medical
treatments could not.
Amanda was proud to have recovered from her addiction, even after Jill had
given up on her.
-[Amanda] It works.
-[Amanda] It's real.
-[Amanda] He helped me.
I'm sticking all these scenes together on the timeline because of the
continuity with John being bald as he prepares for the Bathroom Game and
Amanda's clothing and hair.
Other events that summer include Detectives Sing and Tapp finding Jigsaw's
workshop on Stygian Street, only to discover it was a trap for them.
Tapp gets his spurt slashed, but lives.
Sing isn't so lucky, and he's killed in the Shotgun Trap.
Tapp is discharged from the police force on June 21, according to these signatures,
but he becomes obsessed and decides to take the investigation
into his own hands, renting an apartment across from
Dr. Gordon and hiring a photographer named Adam to keep tabs on him.
This is all part of the five months in between the Reverse Bear Trap and the
Bathroom Game.
As I mentioned before, the Bathroom Game would be held in October 2004.
Funny story when I first started developing a Saw timeline a few years ago,
I began by putting the Bathroom Game in October 2004 just as a placeholder,
because that's when the original Saw came out, and I built everything around that.
Luckily, it ended up working perfectly in relation to all of the other
dates, and I discovered that I got to keep it there.
The movie came out October 29, so although it's not a canon date, I like to
imagine that that's when the Bathroom Game took place.
Before everything goes in motion, John performs a rebirth ceremony, his own
version of a baptism, asking Amanda to give everything to him and assigning
her her first task as a Jigsaw disciple to go kidnap Adam.
So Adam is kidnapped by Amanda,
Dr. Gordon is kidnapped by someone I don't think we actually know, and they are
chained up in the dilapidated bathroom underneath the nerve gas house.
Before the two contestants wake up, John and Amanda put the finishing
touches on the game, with John staging himself as a dead man in the middle
of the floor and Amanda putting Adam into place in the bathtub.
When Adam and Lawrence wake up, they discover the instructions.
Gordon is supposed to kill Adam, and Adam is simply meant to escape.
Neither one of them ends up succeeding.
But Dr.
Gordon does demonstrate his will to survive by cutting off his foot in order
to try to get away.
So before he can fully escape, John catches up, congratulates him on
surviving, and convinces him to become a Jigsaw apprentice.
In the following days, Amanda feels guilty about Adam and returns to the
bathroom to mercy kill him by suffocating him with a plastic bag.
Adam would have starved to death before too long, so that's got to be late
October or early November.
Not long after that, there's some activity overseas.
Logan Nelson is still serving in the military and partakes in The Second
Battle of Fallujah.
This isn't shown in the movies, but it's a real battle that took place in
November and December of 2004.
-[Keith] He got captured. But not before taking out three Taliban.
-[Keith] From what I heard, they tortured the sh*t out of him.
Gordon soon leaves his position at the Angel of Mercy Hospital to work at
St. Eustace Hospital, presumably to distance himself from his coworkers, who
would soon become Jigsaw victims.
After the bathroom game, Jigsaw continues carrying out smaller traps.
One of these, which must have been in late 2004 or early 2005, involved a
woman named Joan who went on television to tell her story.
This inspires a man named Bobby Dagen to pretend to be a Jigsaw victim and
write a book called Survive, which becomes a huge hit.
John doesn't like the fact that Dagen is lying about becoming one of his
victims, so he confronts him at a book signing.
In fact, this must be 2005, entirely based on the fact that John Kramer is
wearing a backwards hat at the age of 51.
Or maybe the backwards hat is to indicate that he's a rebel, and he would
soon demonstrate that.
Remember how his healthcare insurance provider told him he couldn't seek
outside treatment.
He goes ahead and does it anyway by seeking out that Norwegian doctor,
Dr. Cecilia Peterson.
She has a program outside Mexico City.
After going through an operation, scans reveal that the tumor was never removed.
They only pretended to cure him.
John puts each of the people involved in the scam through a new game.
Amanda Young also seems to be involved.
Also, sometime in 2005, detective Eric Matthews files for divorce from his wife,
which greatly harms his relationship with his son, who begins to act
out by stealing and getting in trouble with the law.
Matthews is also investigated by Internal Affairs around this time for
various incidents of say it with me.
One, two, three.
Brutality!
And speaking of which, we get more Logan Nelson updates.
According to his file, he's released by Saddam Hussein loyalists in May of 2005.
Then in July, he returns from the military and goes into treatment for
his PTSD for the next 23 months.
In October, a documentary called Full Disclosure Report piecing together
Jigsaw airs on TV.
Hosted by the amazing and incredible Rich Skidmore.
It goes over the mysteries of what happened the previous year and exposes
the dark side of Eric Matthews.
We know this program airs in October because of this line
-[Rick]  An a chilly night one year ago, each mysteriously vanished.
Some will try to say that Full Disclosure Report is not canon because the
names Paul Stalberg and Mark Rodriguez don't match up with their real names,
Paul Leahy and Mark Wilson.
But don't listen to them.
This could be because middle names or pseudonyms are used for privacy reasons
in the documentary, don't you ever let anyone discredit Rich
Anyway, that leads right up to the beginning of the next major game,
the Nerve Gas House Game.
Hoffman helps John kidnap the test subjects and set them up in the house.
All of these victims are people who Detective Matthews sent to prison by
faking evidence, except for his son Daniel.
Amanda is also in the game, and she's secretly a facilitator.
Each participant learns that they're breathing in a poisonous gas and must
solve puzzles around the house to win antidotes.
By now you're probably screaming at the video, wondering how I know the date
of The Nerve Gas House Game.
Well, we know the date of Saw IV.
It's in April 2006.
And we know that the Nerve Gas House in Saw II was six months earlier.
-[Hoffman] Eric's been missing for six months.
This date also lines up really nicely with the decomposition of the bodies
from the bathroom game.
The last few contestants of The Nerve Gas Game end up discovering the
bathroom at the end, and Adam and Zep are still there.
I consulted a forensic subreddit providing photos of the corpses
and a forensic chem undergrad
undergrad estimated that Adam had been rotting for one to two years.
So everything lines up nicely.
Anyway, it ends with Amanda saving Daniel with the antidote and transporting
him to the Wilson Steel Plant, where he's kept safe.
The entire game was recorded on security cameras.
The next day, Dr. Gordon
helps John by performing surgery on police informant Michael Marks.
Gordon stitches a key behind his eye.
And this is the key to unlock the Venus Fly Death Trap Mask.
Sounds like it should be the name of a metal band.
Michael is unable to get the key, so the mask clamps down on his face.
And that's the end of Michael Marks.
Detectives show up to the crime scene, where there's a clue for Eric Matthews,
leading him to find the location of Jigsaw's hideout,
the Wilson Steel Plant.
And when they arrive, Eric and his team see the footage of the
Nerve Gas House Game, thinking that it was being broadcast live.
While the signal is traced, matthews tries to get answers from Jigsaw and
grows increasingly impatient, which eventually turns to violence.
This is not good for Eric because this is actually his test and he's failed.
So Jigsaw agrees to take him to the Nerve Gas House, where he's sedated by Amanda,
and he wakes up with a chain around his ankle, just like
Dr. Gordon and Adam a year earlier.
But unlike Adam and Gordon, Matthews finds a way to escape without sawing
off an appendage, it involves him breaking the bones in his foot.
Once he escapes, he is confronted by Amanda, and she's not happy about his
survival.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
After a ruthless fight with the hobbled and broken Detective Matthews,
Amanda gets the upper hand and leaves him for dead.
However, someone, presumably John Kramer or Hoffman, ends up saving him and
holding him captive in a cell where his only friend is this rat.
However, Matthews did have someone looking for him on the outside.
Scott Tibbs, a mentally insane, pro Jigsaw wannabe rocker, tries to make his
own documentary on Jigsaw.
He makes it to the press conference following John's escape from Wilson Steel Plant
and interviews a Detective Jenkins about the incident.
He tries to visit Daniel Matthews in the hospital, but gets kicked out.
Ironically, Daniel is a fan and probably would have liked a visit from him.
Then he tries to spread the word about Jigsaw, which doesn't work.
So he makes his own Jigsaw trap and tries to test it on himself and dies.
Nothing of value was lost that day.
And that's the Scott Tibbs documentary, an often forgotten footnote in Saw lore.
Obviously, he wasn't the only one looking for answers.
Police were hard at work to locate one of their own.
They kept Jigsaw's true identity under wraps for a month until November 30, 2005
when it went public and was published in the Metro Gazette newspaper.
I'd assume that after a month of search with no answers, this was a
desperate attempt to find Matthews.
Meanwhile, back in John's camp,
Mr. Kramer knew that his days were numbered and asked
Dr. Gordon to recommend him, a brain surgeon, to buy him
a little more time.
Gordon recommends Dr. Lynn Denlon,
who was perfect because she had ties to John's next big game.
The calendar rolled over to 2006, but while the rest of us were distracted
by bird flu and this trendy little new site called You-Tube,
John was planning his most complex games yet.
He knew there was a good chance that he wouldn't survive this time around,
so he recorded the tape for Jill, expressing his regret about how things ended.
You can tell it was made in the operating room from Saw III,
while John still has his hair, but does not still have the bruises given to him by Matthews,
meaning that this must have been recorded not long before he died.
With Jigsaw's true identity out in the open, police tasked Hoffman with
interrogating Jill Tuck-Kramer, who is represented by John's former business
partner, Art Blank.
Blank is soon abducted and forced into a trap called the Mausoleum Trap with
a man named Trevor.
Dr. Gordon once again helps set this up, stitching Trevor's eyes shut and
Art's mouth closed.
Trevor dies and Blank survives, but Blank is forced to wear a device that'll
sever his spine if he doesn't obey orders.
This would come into play shortly.
This time, there would be a few individual traps before the next big game.
Detective Hoffman and the now promoted Detective Kerry investigate the
aftermath of the classroom trap, a trap set by Amanda and rigged to be inescapable.
This leads to Amanda kidnapping Detective Kerry and setting
her up in another inescapable trap, the Angel Trap.
Kerry's life is cut short in the Angel Trap on April 24, 2006,
four days before she is discovered during the events of Saw III and IV.
-[Hoffman] Kerry was gone for four days,
Which means that it's April 28th when she is finally discovered.
This date was one of the trickiest to determine, because at the end of Saw IV,
we find out that the third and fourth movies took place simultaneously.
These will be known as the Gideon Games because the
conclusion of both games takes place at Gideon Meatpacking Plant.
And in the fourth movie, there's a forensics report matching officer Daniel Riggs
fingerprints to a bullet found at the crime scene that day.
The report is labeled April 28th, and this would be anchor point for a
lot of events, such as Hoffman meets FBI agents Perez and Strahm at the site
of the Angel Trap, and they take over the investigation, looking for the
accomplice that the homicide department couldn't find.
Just hours before the Gideon Games, Hoffman sets up Timothy Young in the rack.
John gives him some engineering tips, and Amanda taunts him, asking
when his test will be.
-[Amanda] Get used to me, cause I’m not going anywhere.
-[Hoffman] You sure about that?
John and Amanda then run into Jill, who begs John to stop what he's doing.
John promises a way out for her when it's all over.
He gives her a key necklace, telling her she'll know what to do with it when
the time is right.
Then we can also assume Hoffman moved Eric Matthews out of his cell and onto
a block of ice at Gideon Meatpacking Plant.
This isn't shown, but it had to have been him.
He also leaves a note for Amanda, letting her know that he's aware that she
had something to do with the death of Gideon, John and Jill's miscarried son.
Their rivalry intensifies.
Finally, he visits Jigsaw one last time in the operating room and receives
instructions for a future game, which would eventually be known as the trial
of the Fatal Five.
Jigsaw was ensuring that his legacy would live on without him.
With that, Hoffman goes to the other room and pretends to tie himself up
next to Eric Matthews, while Amanda goes off to abduct
Dr. Lynn Denlon so that she can perform the surgery on John.
These simultaneous Gideon games involve two main trials the trial of
Jeff Denlon, Lynn's husband, who never learned to move on after the death of their son,
and the trial of Daniel Rigg, a SWAT officer whose obsession with
saving those around him prevents him from living his own life.
This is also secretly a test for Amanda to see if she can control her anger,
seeing as how she's just been killing victims for the last couple traps now
and not really giving them a chance to survive.
At one point, Amanda, probably realizing that she'll fail, warns Lynn and
Jeff's daughter not to trust the one who saves her, which she knew would be Hoffman.
This was Amanda's way of getting revenge on Hoffman, as this
message would make it back to the FBI and would be their first indicator
that Hoffman could be corrupt.
Anyway, just like all of the Chicago Bears head coaches in my lifetime,
literally everyone fails.
Amanda, Jeff, Lynn, Rigg, Matthews, Art, and several less important
characters all end up dead, as does the man himself, Jigsaw.
But you already knew that.
We literally started the video by saying he dies in 2006.
The only meaningful survivor is Hoffman.
When the FBI agent Strahm comes snooping, Hoffman, fittingly, wearing a pig mask,
sneaks up behind him and gives him the old needle and puts him into
the Water Cube trap.
As predicted by Amanda, Hoffman saves Lynn and Jeff's daughter and
is hailed as a hero.
However, he's shocked to find out that Strahm survived his trap as well.
Strahm had used a pen to poke a hole in his trachea, apparently allowing him
to breathe through his neck.
Should have filled it with milk.
Hoffman rookie mistake.
And speaking of mistakes, there's definitely one here in the timeline.
During the autopsy of John Kramer, an autopsy is usually performed the next
day after a death.
And thanks to Strahm, Hoffman being collected by ambulances, they would
have found Kramer in the other bodies immediately.
So one would assume that John's autopsy would occur the next day
April 29th, 2006. Right?
The problem is that the date on John's autopsy tag is October 21st, 2006.
See it's right there.
It doesn't take six months to do an autopsy.
And judging by the lack of decomposition on John's body, it hasn't been very
long since he died.
So that means one of these death dates, April 28th or October 21st
has got to be wrong.
And all we can do is speculate on which one.
Obviously, I think this one is wrong, and John's death was in April.
Here's my rationale.
We later see Hoffman looking at evidence bags containing Strahm's cell phone
and the pen he used to poke the hole in his neck.
Those give us a month and a day when the evidence was collected May 7th and
the day that the evidence was moved to storage, which appears to be July 7th.
So if the evidence was collected on May 7th, that means they were collecting
evidence from the warehouse for the next nine days after the Gideon Games.
So the October 21st tag doesn't make any sense.
Maybe Logan Nelson's cousin was in charge of putting the tags on and just
put the wrong date or something.
In the meantime, John's executor calls up Jill and shows her the final video
recording that John left for her and gives her this box.
This could have taken place anywhere from May 8th, 2006 to sometime in July 2006.
All we know is that an executor must wait at least ten days before
probating the will in New Jersey where these movies take place.
And when we next see Hoffman, it must be July 2006, because this is the same
day that we see the evidence bag, which says that the evidence was moved to
storage on July 7th.
And this is storage.
So July 7th is already in the past.
There are a few things to note from this time period.
Hoffman is promoted for his heroics, and FBI Agent Perez is pronounced dead
from her injuries sustained during the Daniel Rigg trial.
But in reality, the Bureau is faking her death for her own safety.
Soon they would discover the true nature of what they're up against.
John Kramer may be gone, but Jigsaw lives forever through the work of his
followers.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
While Hoffman starts preparing the next game, he receives an anonymous
letter claiming to know who he really is.
This letter was sent by Dr.
Lawrence Gordon, who Hoffman doesn't know about, so he suspects it's from
Special Agent Strom, who basically accuses him of being John Kramer's
accomplice.
Strahm follows up on this theory by doing a deep investigation of his own
into Hoffman, which is the inspiration behind one of my favorite Letterboxd reviews.
This movie is about a detective figuring out the plots of Saw III
and Saw IV.
In the meantime, Hoffman cuts the ribbon on the next major game
The Trial of the Fatal Five.
These subjects were all involved in allowing a building fire to occur years
ago and to be covered up, which furthered their own careers at the expense
of others.
Their tests were created for them to work together in order to survive.
As this is going on, Hoffman makes contact with Special Agent Strahm's superior,
special Agent Erickson, or as I like to call him,
J Jonah Erickson.
He starts to plant the seeds in Erickson's head of Strahm possibly being
Jigsaw's other accomplice.
He sets things up at the location where The Fatal Five Game is being held to
make it look like Strahm was behind it all.
-[Jameson] They’re crap. Crap. Crap. Mega Crap.
So after luring Strahm into a trap, the Glass Coffin Trap, Strahm fails to
follow directions and gets crushed by the collapsing room while Hoffman is
carried to safety.
That is where Saw V ends and Saw VI begins.
But timeline wise, we're staying right here.
In July 2006, Saw VI would take place less than a week later.
-[Reporter] Just this past week, a new so called game was discovered with grizzly results.
If that's not enough proof for you, consider the fact that Hoffman
retrieves Strahm's hand and uses it to place fingerprints at various crime scenes,
like the next trap, The Pound of Flesh Trap.
If it were any longer than a week later, the hand would already be starting
to decompose.
At the crime scene following The Pound of Flesh,
J Jonah Erickson admits that they faked Agent Perez's death.
So you know those flowers that you never sent the grieving family?
Don't bother!
The two would continue their investigation despite Strom looking
very guilty at this point.
There were still a couple more games that John wanted his followers to carry
out after his death.
Remember his old friend William Easton, the health insurance guy?
He was about to get his comeuppance.
The instructions for this game were originally in the hands of Jill,
left behind in the box that he left for her in his will.
But Hoffman shows up at her practice and usurps control.
Because Hoffman is a megalomaniac.
So the next game would be held at Rowan Zoological Institute and feature
William Easton being forced to make the same kind of life or death decisions
about who will receive healthcare coverage, only now in person regarding his
own employees.
You know, this one's gonna be spicy.
Meanwhile, in the background, Erickson and Perez discover that the knife
used to cut the Jigsaw piece from the latest victim matches the knife used
to cut the Jigsaw piece from Seth Baxter, but doesn't match any of the other victims.
Their suspicion of Hoffman continues to grow as they learn that
Strahm's fingerprints were placed after he was already dead.
And eventually, they descramble the voice on the Seth Baxter Jigsaw tape,
revealing none other than Detective Mark Hoffman.
-[Hoffman] Right now you’re feeling helpless.
Hoffman is forced to kill all three FBI agents.
He burns down the field office, once again marking the place with Strahm's fingerprints,
which I just realized doesn't make that much sense, because
you'd think the FBI will be able to analyze the fingerprints again
and determine that they were planted there postmortem.
In the meantime, Jill drops off a tape at
Dr. Gordon's office at
St. Eustace's Hospital, one of John's secret final requests.
Then she goes to the zoo and places a copy of Hoffman's note to Amanda,
essentially letting him know that he's in trouble because there shouldn't be
anyone who knows about this.
When he sits down in his chair, Jill activates a shock device.
He's incapacitated, and she puts him in a new Reverse Bear Trap and leaves
him for dead.
Hoffman does manage to escape, but it still does some damage, ripping open
his cheek, which he stitches back together in a new hideout later that week.
Finally, after spending four straight movies in 2006, there is another time skip.
Hoffman goes into hiding for eight months, not emerging again until
March 2007.
This date is a little easier to figure out.
During the hunt for Hoffman, one of the police computers displays an email
with the date March 12th, 2007.
Most of Saw 7 takes place the same day, but there are a couple of things
that take place before this.
The first is the Public Execution Trap, where two men caught in a love
triangle must decide who will be eliminated in front of a live audience at a
shopping center.
This is an interesting one to place.
Legend has it that this scene was originally going to show
John and Dr. Gordon spectating in the crowd.
This would place it pretty far in the past, but since it's not in the movie,
I'll assume it's meant to take place closer to the rest of Saw 7 in
early 2007.
Looking at weather patterns, I see people wearing jackets and hats, which
would put us closer to the other scenes, like Jill's dream, where we see
snow, and Bobby Dagen's abduction, where we see his breath.
Personally, I'm placing the public execution trap in March 2007.
It also makes sense there, because Hoffman's return would probably spark
Jill to fear for her life again and go seek protection from Matt Gibson,
the internal affairs detective from Hoffman's past.
If we're putting the public execution trap in March, then we also have to
put the next scene, Bobby Dagen's TV interview, in March as well.
After that, we have the Car Trap, which is the same day as that March 12th
email that I mentioned earlier.
So the rest of the Saw saga is pretty easy to place.
The Car Trap is designed to bring retribution to a group of racists.
Bobby Dagen hosts a self help group for Jigsaw survivors,
which is remarkable, just remarkable.
-[Dr. Gordon] Promotional DVD
And after this, Bobby is kidnapped and placed in the
Clear Dawn Hospital Game, where he and his team are
ironically forced to survive a Jigsaw game much like Bobby claimed he had in his book.
Meanwhile, through a series of clues, Hoffman leads Matt Gibson to his hideout,
where a motion activated turret is waiting for him, and Hoffman
finally gets the revenge he promised all those years ago.
Hoffman hides inside of a body bag to sneak his way into the police station,
where he takes out many officers en route to the last person he needs to get
revenge on, Jill Tuck.
He sets her up in an old classic, the Reverse Bear Trap, and third time's a
charm with that device.
Finally, after seven movies, we get to see it tear someone's face apart from
the inside.
And it is so satisfying.
But Hoffman is still on the loose!
He packs up some money and guns so he can start a new life, and it blows up
his hideout in the air hangar.
But he's intercepted by Jigsaw's greatest asset,
Dr. Lawrence Gordon, and two more unknown apprentices in pig masks.
After sedating Detective Hoffman well, I guess we can't call him that
anymore. I assume he's fired.
But after sedating Hoffman, gordon locks him inside the bathroom.
Yes, that bathroom.
But this time with no chance to escape.
-[Dr. Gordon] Game over!
-[Hoffman] No!!!!!
And for a while, it was game over.
But aren't you forgetting about someone, one month later, conveniently
missing out on the whole bloody sauce saga? Logan Nelson would be released
from his PTSD treatment by Dr. Perry.
But I would say that he was anything but cured.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
On October 5th, 2007, Logan Nelson was awarded a Purple Heart, an award given to
U.S. Military personnel who were wounded or killed in battle.
For the next eight years, there are no Jigsaw related killings that we know
about, and things would go back to normal.
But normal doesn't necessarily mean quiet.
We don't know exactly when, but Logan got the job as the medical examiner at
St. Peter's Hospital.
From this position, he would see a lot of incompetence from the
local detective Brad Halloran.
Criminals seemed to go free, while many innocent people ended up dead on
Logan's table.
In 2009, on the south side of the city, a new Metro police detective named
Zeke Banks was partnered with Officer Peter Dunleavy under a policy called
Article Eight, cops had the power to do essentially whatever they wanted in
the name of stopping crime, which led to a lot of corruption in the force.
One day, Dunleavy shot a witness who was planning to testify against another
officer just to keep him quiet.
The victim's son, William Emerson, witnessed the crime and came to praise
Zeke when he did the right thing by reporting Dunleavy to Internal Affairs.
I'm putting this in 2009 because it's twelve years before the main events of
Spiral in 2021.
-[Angie] It's been twelve years?
-[Det. Banks] Yes, twelve years.Twelve years ago, I turn in a dirty cop, I get a medal for it.
-[Det. Banks] Big deal.
Well, at one point, the son, William Emerson, says it's 15 years.
-[William] I've been loyal to you since the first day we met 15 years ago.
-[William] The day your partner killed my father.
So it looks like another error there, but I'm going to assume it's twelve years,
because that's said more often, and also 15 years
doesn't make sense.
That would put the Dunleavy incident in 2006, and we never saw any of those
characters during the Saw saga.
Hoffman even claimed that he was the last one left at one point.
In 2011, a degenerate gambler named Malcolm Neal was partially
responsible responsible for the death of his wife when people he owed money
broke into his home and slit
Mrs. Neal's throat.
This put him in Logan's bad graces.
It must have happened in 2011, because it's stated to be five years before
the main events of Jigsaw, which are most likely in 2016.
-[Logan] Malcolm Neal.
-[Logan] I remember that case.
-[Logan] His wife was murdered five years ago.
Malcolm Neal probably wasn't enough to convince Logan to hold his own Jigsaw
game, but what would happen next would.
In 2014, Logan's wife, Christine Nelson, was killed by a loose meth addict
named Edgar Munson, not to be confused with burnout Eddie Munson from
Stranger Things.
To make matters even worse, Munson was free because of a failed conviction
by Detective Halloran.
2014 is two years before the main events of Jigsaw.
-[Det Hunt] It's been two years since Christine passed.
This was probably the tipping point, and Logan decided to recreate
John Kramer's Barn Game to punish Halloran and test himself to see if he could be
as good of a Jigsaw as his master.
So in 2016, he holds his own, which I'll call Logan Nelson's Barn Game,
because what the else would I call it? This is stated several times to be
ten years after John's death.
-[Ryan] Kramer's been dead for ten years.
-[Logan] John Kramer's dead and has been for ten years.
-[Lab Tech] This is a blood sample, a perp, taken a decade ago.
There's a bit of a contradiction when Nelson says that John's original game,
which he did as a secret test before all the other games, was ten years ago.
Jigsaw died three years after John Kramer's barn game, so they can't both be
ten years ago.
It's likely that Nelson was generalizing.
He was essentially saying this was all about a decade ago.
Or maybe his PTSD from the war has really affected his math skills.
Actually, we kind of know that he's using the term ten years ago kind of
loosely, because he also says this
-[Logan] Ten years ago, I came out of the war a broken man.
Except his file says that he came out of the war in 2005.
So clearly Nelson is just clumping that whole time period between 2003 and 2006 together in his mind.
Anyway, Nelson puts three contestants in his version of the Barn Game and
deposits the bodies in public for Halloran to find after each death.
Each of them is someone connected to Halloran's past cases.
He also ends up framing Halloran by leaving the puzzle pieces in his freezer
and leading him to the pig farm, where the two of them would be the final players.
And Halloran is scared into confessing all of his dirty police
work, which Logan gets an audio recording of
-[Logan] Some will think it's Jigsaw.
-[Logan] Some will suspect you.
-[Logan] But no one will suspect me.
And with all the evidence he needs, logan slices Halloran's head into seven
pieces with this laser cutter device.
He would not be the only person to try to hold his own Jigsaw games however.
William Emerson, the boy who watched his father fall to the corrupt
police force, was grown up and wanted revenge.
That takes us to Spiral, where corrupt police officers on the South Side
Metro PD come to find themselves, one by one, caught in a series of traps.
I'm placing the beginning of Spiral on July 4th, 2021.
The July 4 part is obvious.
It happens during an American Independence Day celebration.
My calculations on the year are a little less scientific.
At one point, we see the file of Detective Marv Bozwick, and it says he was
born on May 9th, 1981.
The actor that played Marv, Daniel Petronijevic, was also born in 1981, and
he doesn't appear to be aged up or aged down in makeup.
He's just playing his actual 40 year old self.
Also, Spiral came out in 2021, so it's pretty easy to assume that this is
when it was set.
Anyway, Marv is killed in the Subway Trap on July 4th.
The next day is July 5th, and Zeke is forced to team up with rookie Detective
William Schenk.
This is William Emerson, the new Jigsaw, but he changed his name so that
nobody would make the connection.
As they delve deeper into the case, they uncover a dark web of corruption
within the police force, and more and more crooked cops are put into Jigsaw traps.
Zeke takes the lead on the case.
They question Bozwick's mourning wife, and during some late night research,
another cop named Fitch is put into the Finger Trap.
The next day is July 6th.
Fitch's fingers are discovered at a freeway underpass, along with a new
message from the new Jigsaw, and the body is later found at a bread factory.
Zeke and Schenk investigate a drug dealer who may have ties to the case, and
they question Zeke's old partner, Dunleavy.
That night, Zeke's father, a former cop, also goes missing.
And our last date on the timeline for now is July 7th.
And I know I've been counting correctly, because we can see the date is 7/7
on a security camera feed.
Schenk doesn't show up for work that day, and police receive a new package
containing skin with Schenk's tattoo.
A body is discovered at a local butcher shop, and they assume that it's Schenk.
The police chief is then attacked in the evidence room and put into
the Wax Trap.
Zeke continues to search for his dad, but he's kidnapped by someone in a pig mask
and finds himself in a series of tests in an abandoned soap factory.
As you can probably guess, I'll refer to this as the Soap Factory Game.
At the end, he finds Schenk alive, and to his surprise, Schenk wants to team
up with him.
His proposal is for Zeke to help him find the dirty cops, and Schenk would
give them Jigsaw style punishments.
He brings him to the final test, where Zeke finds his dad in the IV drip trap.
Zeke must decide between stopping Schenk or freeing his dad.
In the end, Zeke saves his dad, but Schenk has a backup plan.
When the SWAT team cuts down the door, it triggers a machine that puppeteers
Mr. Banks to look like a threat, and they're all forced to shoot him down.
In all of the commotion, Schenk gets away.
So there are now at least three Jigsaws running around out there.
Dr. Gordon, Logan Nelson, and William Emerson, aka William Schenk.
In the end, there was just one scene that I absolutely couldn't place.
In Saw 7
during the survivor support group, we meet a new survivor named Sidney, who
tells about her experiences in the Lawnmower Trap.
There's no indication of when this happened, but if I had to put it somewhere,
I would put it in the first quarter of 2006 before the Classroom Trap
or the Angel Trap.
Maybe Amanda put Sidney in the lawnmower trap, and she was frustrated when
Sidney survived, and that's why she decided to make future traps inescapable.
So that's the Saw timeline as it currently stands.
It's not perfect by any means, but there are really only a few
major contradictions that can't be explained.
You could argue that there shouldn't have been HDTVs in some of the
flashback scenes before HD was popular, but technically it was possible.
I think after Saw X, there's really no room in the timeline to do anything
with John Kramer.
But as Eleanor so eloquently explained,
-[Eleanor] Jigsaw lives forever.
-[Eleanor] Through the work of his followers.
So it'll be interesting to see what happens with our current surviving Jigsaws
and who might take up the mantle next.
I've got individual analysis episodes on each of John Kramer's devoted followers,
as well as some other Saw characters.
You can find them in that playlist on the left for all things Saw
Make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week.
Ring the deathbell for all notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.